[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora per conoscerci buonasera a tutti
per conoscerci vorrei prima raccontarvi
e 22 cose mi sono successe che mi hanno
insegnato a creare questi mesi tra
l'arte del mondo dell'impresa che non
avrei mai immaginato poter creare allora
immaginiamoci un museo dell'utero ma un
museo dell'orologio siamo lontani ma
immaginiamo cielo prima del coin con 15
mila visitatori all'anno siamo
13 chilometri di galleria 2 mila
dipendenti e un sacco di crisi di liti
lavori succedono un sacco di cose siamo
in un weekend in cui sono reperibili c'è
un grosso problema di umidità che sta
compromettendo una scalinata
importantissima senza la quale si blocca
tutto allora
ennesima chiamata ennesima corsa si va
so che ho pochi minuti per percorrere e
poi qualche secondo per prendere una
decisione ci diamo appuntamento con il
servizio tecnico il nuovo comincia a
correre
attraversiamo le sale o al mio pass
scorciatoie meandri andiamo avanti e in
realtà quello che si riesce a fare di
avvicinarsi con rapidità e attraversando
queste sale la situazione peggiora il
guardiano mi richiama sta accadendo
acqua quindi bisogna intervenire
rapidamente arrivo c'è un'ultima sala
quella che noi chiamiamo le le scuse al
lucro è una sala in cui quando ci si
ferma insomma abbiamo tutto il xix
secolo francese abbiamo david dell'acqua
gerico siamo due passi dal rinascimento
italiano
due passi dalla gioconda se
la cronca alla fia il tutto a un certo
punto mi mi ribello a queste corse dico
ma com'è possibile che io attraverso
queste sale senza nemmeno fermarmi un
attimo a guardare questi capolavori e a
vedere quello di più bello che l'uomo
abbia mai creato nei secoli e invece mi
occupo del forse del più brutto cioè un
rubinetto lasciato aperto chissà da dove
viene tutta quest'acqua
siamo sempre in una corsa
c'è il mio il conservatore che mi
accompagna che si ferma e dice senti ma
tu hai già fatto una passeggiata nel
bosco tu hai già respirato l'aria pura e
hai già fatto una passeggiata nel bosco
per prendere delle belle decisioni
perché tu quando attraversi una foresta
ma che ti fermi davanti a ogni albero
per sapere in che anno è nato quante
foglie ha perso quest'anno oppure se la
purezza del suo verde la stessa di
quello vicino respiri
assorbi tutta la l'armonia alla bellezza
e forse tutto quello che il tuo corpo il
tuo spirito possono prendere per
prendere delle buone decisioni
molte persone fanno delle passeggiate
nel bosco per prendere le decisioni
importanti e allora perché non ti
succede la stessa cosa qui ha
attraversato forse uno dei più bei
paesaggi il paesaggio della bellezza
creata dall'uomo è perché non non ti
sente al massimo sono sicuro che la tua
la decisione che prenderà i sul tuo
rubinetto aperto sarà la migliore
mi sono effettivamente mi sono fermata
poi mi sono occupata del rubinetto
voglio rassicurarvi ma mi sono fermata
ed era forse la prima volta che qualcuno
mi faceva capire l'impatto della
bellezza e dell'arte sul nostro cervello
e allora in queste chiacchierate che
creano dei nessi assurdi tra cose che
sembrano totalmente
divergenti
vorrei adesso trasportarvi in un altro
ambiente allora è un ambiente di
chiacchierate con degli artisti
non ci crederete ma mi sono ritrovata a
fare delle chiacchierate con degli
artisti parlando dei grandi temi
manageriali che occupano oggi le più
grandi imprese più grandi manager del
mondo
ogni tanto mi dicevo avrei potuto essere
a davos al world economic forum forse
avrà infatti gli stessi ragionamenti
lo so che siete scettici era per
convincere dividevo trasportare lasciate
louvre lasciate parigi
attraversiamo le alpi scendiamo dagli
appennini arriviamo a roma
arriviamo a villa medici solo uno dei
più bei palazzi della città ma anche la
più antica più grande residenza di
artisti al mondo e
stiamo in una settimana normale faccio
spesso il giro degli atelier incontro
gli artisti per vedere se hanno bisogno
di qualcosa e
mi mi capita di entrare in un atelier di
un artista una disegnatrice e scrittrice
che ha già pubblicato moltissimi libri
di successo cioè chiariamo mi spiega
come fa per creare che mi spiega che
ogni volta si immagina di essere di
fronte al suo primo libro
no dico mai una bella esperienza un bel
successo tutti gli editori tt ricercano
perché fai così e mi dice sai è la
concentrazione che mi serve per avere la
forza di proporre per inventarmi
qualcosa di nuovo e anche per lasciare
qualche dubbio qualche fragilità
che sono sicura che il pubblico apprezza
più di una cosa
netta e chiara e
mi fermo un attimo ho fatto
un'associazione qualche a qualche giorno
prima avevo sentito un discorso di un
gran de sio
che si chiama drew houston che il ceo di
dropbox che si era rivolto agli studenti
delle mighty con provocando un grande
entusiasmo questi ragazzi che
inneggiavano perché aveva detto il
vostro problema non è il fallimento il
vostro problema è quando siete troppo a
vostro agio nel mestiere non avete più
questa voglia di proporre non avete più
questa voglia di lasciare un po di
dubbio di fragilità in quello che fate
non mi fa ridere perché stavo parlando
con una con un artista mi ritrovo a
pensare alle mighty aia ea e al dropbox
quindi vabbè proseguiamo continua questa
questa chiacchierata
faccio il giro capito davanti a
all'atelier di un di uno scultore e
pittore si chiama suns mattia un
francese bravissimo soprattutto nel
disegno mi piace da morire quando
appunto estrema fragilità con queste
forme invece monumentali che si
contrastano facciamo una bella
chiacchierata non mi dice come la scuola
delle belle arti
lo ha salvato da un'infanzia
difficilissima di povertà di esclusione
di razzismo e mi dice che li faccio il
legame con tanti imprenditori
l'ultima che ho sentito era randi
zuckerberg chi dice non attenzione a
quelli che vi vogliono lasciare
nell'angolo in cui siete e comunque
proseguiamo questa chiacchierata e lui
mi dice sai il fatto di dominare la
tecnica del disegno lui è un grandissimo
disegnatore che ha imparato a disegnare
dal vivo
mi ha permesso poi di uscire dagli
schemi cioè o dominato la tecnica per
poi uscirne e fare a modo mio essere
originale avere successo nel mondo
dell'arte e in quel momento entra un
signore melo melo presenta è
l'imprenditore che ha appena acquistato
il quadro anzi non sa non l'ha
acquistato ha finanziato la sua
produzione ea è un imprenditore nel
campo degli utensili da cucina in ho
inventato una macchinetta che taglia a
fettine piccole la frutta e la verdura
ha avuto un successo mondiale con questo
è e non ha sentito la chiacchierata che
abbiamo fatto prima con l'artista e mi
dicesse io quello il mio successo è
stato determinato quando io ho studiato
e o dominato tutte le tecniche di
vendita degli utensili da cucina e poi
ho capito che il mio utensile non si
sarebbe mai venduto così perché la gente
avrebbe avuto voglia di provarlo prima
di comprarlo e quindi
mi parlava con gli stessi termini di
dominare una tecnica per poi uscire
dagli schemi e inventare un percorso suo
per un'altra volta mi ritrovo a
non dico mi immagino a davos sono sempre
a roma villa medici ma
non c'è discorso di imprenditore che non
citi l'innovazione la creatività come un
punto forte una condizione di successo
per la propria impresa e non c'è analisi
prospettiva dei prossimi dieci anni che
non dica che certo le competenze
tecnologiche saranno importantissime per
rispondere a questo sviluppo
incredibile della tecnologia però ci
serviranno forse in modo più
sorprendente anche anche delle
competenze cognitive superiori
l'etica le competenze comportamentali
relazionali
e questo forse che abbiamo lasciato un
po da parte nelle nostre formazioni sia
iniziali che professionali
e allora mi viene da da riprendere un
altro grande manager
tim cook che appunto ha fatto ha detto
questa frase incredibile sono un
ingegnere innamorato della razionalità
diceva in live innamorato della
razionalità ma le decisioni più
importanti non gli ho mai prese su
queste basi è proprio il nostro grande
difetto e non
dar fiducia la nostra intuizione e
allora che cosa allena la nostra
intuizione come facciamo allenare
quell'empatia che è così necessaria è
questo che mi interessava quando ho
iniziato questo percorso di ponte tra
l'impresa e l'arte la creazione
ovviamente bisogna abbattere un muro
quello che separa oggi l'impresa dal
mondo dell'arte tramite forse le scienze
cognitive e sociali che vi possono
legare allora cosa ci dicono cosa ci
dice la neuroscienza ci dice che la
creazione è un processo unico dell'uomo
che lo distingue da tutte le altre
specie viventi e che non solo e unico ma
è anche universale sulla stessa
creatività che o quando sono un
dirigente che inventa una soluzione
nuova in azienda è la stessa cosa nel
mio cervello
rispetto all'artista che crea
un'opera d'arte o allo scienziato che
realizza una grande scoperta scientifica
e allora è quel modo di passare in un
mondo che non è dominata dalla realtà e
di passare in un mondo in cui non esiste
non sono capace già stato provato non ce
la faremo
in un mondo altro allora mi direte
questo è venuta da parigi per dirci
un'idea per darci un'idea che forse ha
più di 500 anni siamo alla fine del
medioevo cento anni di crisi crollo
demografico grandi pandemie la
popolazione decimata così come le
competenze così come la stabilità la
voglia di futuro e poi che cosa cambia
invece nel quattrocento nel cinquecento
cambia la fisionomia del nostro uomo
d'affari del nostro commerciante di
quello che ha deciso oltre avere un
saper un savoir faire commerciale e
finanziario ha deciso di aggiungerci due
cose l'ingegno versatile come si diceva
e la cultura
e allora cosa fa incomincia a dirti che
il processo artistico gli interessa
perché non solo porta al bello ma anche
gli interessa come processo come
capacità a inventarsi mondi nuovi vuole
scoprire mondi nuovi tra l'altro reali e
immaginari e incomincia a scegliere in
xvi mette li sponsorizza
sceglie
seleziona sostiene e valorizza e quindi
crea un valore a partire dalla dalla
ricerca e capisce che i ceti inferiori e
medi possono aumentare la loro domanda e
certi superiori possono assorbire grandi
prodotti di lusso
il vetro la seta poi la carta poi la
stampa poi le conoscenze e possiamo dare
un
del rinascimento
allora io mi dico quello che abbiamo
vissuto nel 2020 dopo decine di anni di
grandi progressi tecnologici è qualcosa
di sconvolgente a livello individuale
collettivo nelle imprese
abbiamo scoperto nuove competenze anche
all'interno dei team nelle imprese che
non pensavamo importanti la capacità
inventarsi una reazione quando appunto
abbiamo un piano imprevedibile o che il
piano a non funziona
ci rimane anche una voglia di riflettere
una voglia di fare un po diversamente e
allora mi chiedo non ci sentiamo una
grande responsabilità nella rinascita
che che deve avvenire
noi imprenditori dirigenti
persone che decidono nel mondo pubblico
e privato non ci sentiamo di voler
creare un nuovo rinascimento un
rinascimento dell'era digitale e allora
io dico apriamo le porte al alla vita
delle creativi apriamo le porte all'arte
ea e cerchiamo di posizionarla al centro
e non ai margini della nostra vita e
della vita delle nostre imprese ed è
questo che forse ci farà venire un nuovo
rinascimento ma ricordiamoci che dipende
da noi e dipende da cosa sapremo
da cosa sapremo accogliere nelle nostre
nelle nostre vite allora questo mi
piaceva mostrarvi è un'opera d'arte
incredibile in cui si vede come un
piccolo libro in questo caso è il libro
e il castello di kafka può far vacillare
creare una fragilità che pone delle
domande quindi o cerchiamo una soluzione
per uscirne oppure crolla tutto
c'è stato nel mondo dell'arte questa
questa volontà di mostrare questo padre
coat e cioè di non guardare le cose come
fanno gli altri
allora quello che mi interessa dirvi e
creiamo un nuovo rinascimento e mettiamo
l'arte la creazione con i suoi processi
ai suoi protagonisti al centro della
della nostra vita
grazie mille
[Applauso]